These are our 3 answers. Fantastic work if you've figured those out. For our
first problem we want to combine the routes of 5. So we'll have 2 square roots
of 5 minus 5 square roots of 5. When we subtract 2 minus 5 we'll get negative 3
groups of 5. For the roots of 11 we'll have 4 root 11 minus 1 root 11. Keep in
mind that there's a 1 in front of this square root of 11. So, when we subtract
4 minus 1 we'll get positive 3 times root 11. This second one is really tricky.
You want to pay attention to the index of the radicals and the radicands. Here
the index is a 2. But here the index is a 3. This means that these 2 radicals
are not like terms. We have a square root of 2 and a cubed root of 2. This
means that we can't add the 2 terms together which means we just list them as a
sum. It might have been easy to make the mistake of writing 10 root 2. Or 10
times the cubed root of 2. But again, the indexes are not the same. So these
would not be correct. For our third one, we want to combine the 5th roots of x.
The indexes are 5, all match. And the radicand are all x. So we have like
terms. So I have 3 plus 5 plus 1 times the 5th root of x. This would make 9
times the 5th 3 of x and our answer. This positive 3 is not like terms with
anything else so we just carry it on and add it to the sum in our final answer.